we've talked quite a bit about how
finding a new home is no easy task right
now but
one part of the valley is seeing some
success we're talking about north las
vegas that's where we find joe muller
with more on what is expected in that
area joe
well christian we're used to talking
about areas like summerlin or henderson
well it seems
north las vegas is a popular area right
now a lot of people turning here for
new homes sales here are going through
the roof
now this is the valley vista community
it's a master plan community and they're
selling
very fast one real estate agent we spoke
with says there's a major growth in this
area in the future
we're still looking at houses we we're
thinking about moving in the next couple
months mark hillers and his family are
looking at new homes
we've considered older homes actually
put an offer on a couple of them but we
lost we offer full price and it's not
enough they came to north las vegas a
place that is attracting thousands
many because of the cheaper prices
there's all kinds of stuff being built
up around here just like being
anywhere else in town as more moved to
southern nevada master plans like valley
vista and north las vegas continue to
pop up
north las vegas is expected to be the
number one community for new
construction
in southern nevada for the next 10 years
and is currently that
holds that position now bob hamrick is a
real estate agent from coldwell banker
he says north las vegas saw new home
sales triple in the last two years
and the demand is now greater than
before significantly to do with with
land prices and the ability to there's a
lot of land in north las vegas
and i would again say that mayor lee has
been aggressive
to make it easy for builders to build in
that area he says this master plan
community sold 1073 homes in 2020
alone with the demand high and supply
low he expects the waiting list for
homes even here
to continue what we're noticing is that
people can work
for their employer from a different
place than where they are
employed hiller says finding a home
regardless of the area is not an easy
thing to do right now
it's tough right now it's tough right
now
now back out here live i did end up
talking to several people who recently
moved into these neighborhoods here in
the valley vista community and they say
many of them are moving from out of
state because they're able to work from
home and
others say they can't beat the prices of
north las vegas so that led them
to come up here and buy a home reporting
live in north las vegas joe mohler
8 news now